ladies and gentlemen
welcome to wild ride and god bless every
single one of you who said
where's the new show last week when we
didn't have an episode
because i was too busy getting duct
taped to stuff
but i've never said this get ready for
the funniest episode we've ever recorded
by far
ladies and gentlemen jim jeffries yeah
dude
how you doing man thanks for having me
dude thank you for doing it man so i
watched
intolerant last night your new special
on netflix
it's [ __ ] fabulous i really but i
really genuinely mean that
and to qualify the statement to to give
it
some credibility i thought you seemed
quite pissed drunk on the previous
special what was going on on that um
i wasn't i wasn't drunk in the other one
i was i i
i can't remember i made the the one
before that i had a couple of drinks in
between the two recordings so there
might have been some scenes because i
think the latest show
i was more drunk in the first show but i
wasn't drunk i was sweating a lot
right well i mean suffice it to say i
think that this new one
intolerant is [ __ ] fabulous
not that you've ever made bad comedy i'm
a fan like you're on my top three list
ah thanks you're probably wondering who
i am oh yeah i never do this this is
scott
randolph yeah what's going on dude
i think you guys have met before yeah
yeah i think we went down to your when
you were filming that uh
right when we did jim's podcast yes this
is scott randolph up in the front off
camera we have
paul and of course wendy right here
what's going on
jim how are you i've i've followed
wendy's story online i know everything
about whitney
oh brilliant man brilliant so uh
this was interesting when i reached out
to you about doing this uh
you know we had a little bit of banter
on text about the
the pandemic and and you expressed some
gratitude for
for you know you said i just needed to
slow down a little bit
it was a blessing kind of yeah i i
didn't realize
you know that i hadn't had time off in
sort of 20 years and and it wasn't as
much
time off because you know doing stand-up
comedy often you have time off you have
you know you have your whole days off
sometimes you know and you're only
working for an hour and a half at night
and all that sort of stuff but i i
needed a day off from
stress or from trying to sell a project
or trying to get a project up and
running or something like that you know
like you know what i'm talking about you
just take yourself to a billboard
i needed time off from that you know and
so
but now i feel like that's sort of ended
now because everything's
it doesn't feel like the pandemic the
the deaths haven't slowed down but
everyone's just got off [ __ ] it we had
to go
and now the traffic's back and you know
i i just
i just think with this this this disease
or this virus
we're all going to get it eventually and
you just have to hope for the best right
stay away from old people
right it seems that i already did get it
because i tested positive for the
antibodies
when do you think you had it no [ __ ]
clue
no [ __ ] clear i had a regular covid
test where they put the thing up your
nose
it was negative i went back like a month
later and i
and i the the nose one negative but the
blood test for antibodies i don't even
know why i got it but it was positive
no [ __ ] clue when i got it
yeah i wanted that blood test for the
antibodies i had the nose several times
but
i think i had it in february but
yeah who knows and does anybody's last
forever are you going to have it
you're going to be gone forever they do
not last forever uh
but while they do last you can be a
[ __ ] hero
and go and donate plasma i've got my
appointment next week
yeah yeah yeah that's good
and you can also you can also shag
people for a few weeks
that's that's going to be a big selling
point that you can go to people
i can't give it to you that's must be
nice
right yeah it's damn right so uh
now how old's your boy now you mentioned
his age in the special a couple times
he's seven he's seven going into going
into year two
like next week and it's like
he hasn't been to school for six months
we've been home schooling
but homeschooling's a difficult one
because homeschooling
you know you you hope you i don't know
there's other parents that at the school
who are doctors and
and lawyers and stuff like that and i
don't really know how to do long
division
like i'm googling everything i'm
teaching him like i know how to do maths
in the head
right i know how to add two numbers in
my head but i don't know the way to
actually properly do it with carrying
the one and all that type of stuff
so i think my kid may be dumber at the
end of the
whole pandemic and then there's other
kids who may excel because their parents
are smart or something so i'm a bit
nervous about going into year two
yeah when you say year two that's second
grade
no yeah you crack the code
[Laughter]
no flyers on you
this thing there's things about america
i've been there for 13 years
and i i'll never understand little tiny
things like i still don't get
dude jim jeffries just rules and before
he breaks down what he can't understand
about america i want to clear something
up with you guys
a lot of you watching me do this show
are asking
why would i wear two watches and yes
i've got my smart watch i'd love to get
texts on it and stuff like that
but on my other wrist right here it's
not a watch this is a woop band
and why do i wear that because this
thing gives me
insights into my health my sleep my
recovery
all of this stuff related to my fitness
that i will
never get from any smart watch i
love my woop band and what is woop it's
a membership
service that helps me keep track of
everything this band knows exactly when
i laid down
how much sleep i get how recovered my
body is
all of my workouts everything the
insights are incredible they all give it
to me on this wonderful app
and i love it i want you to try it too
so go to woop.com that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com and use the promo code stevo
at checkout and you're gonna get 15 off
your order
again that's 15 off your order if you
use the promo code stevo
at checkout when you go to woop.com
you're going to thank me for it
now jim jeffries complain about america
is there really a prime queen that you
all vote for
that seems like an archaic system where
on your last day of school when you have
a dance you
you decide who the most popular kid is
does that actually happen
yeah that's real it didn't happen at my
school but i went to high school
in england and uh i did yeah i went to
the american school in london
england and it was just uh
i'm glad you put england on the end
there if you said london you might
thought you're up in canada
yeah fair enough but they don't do
anything like that in australia
high school they don't do anything like
that in high school in australia or
no we have we have a we have a dance
that we call like a formal which is the
equivalent of our prom but
we don't have prime king and queens
and we don't we don't have middle school
we just have
primary school in high school you have
years one to six and then seven to
twelve
and our years your this will spin you
out right
our high school year goes from january
to december because of summer so our
summer break is in december
so i find it weird here that the school
year ends in the middle of the year
and you're the class of half of a year
and a half per year now we're for the
full year
we're like your tax year right that
makes a bunch of sense that does make
more sense
yeah they also they also stop doing
homework in australia too right
we don't have to do homework did you say
yeah remember that guy on the boat with
it is the whole [ __ ] thing
and we were in fiji and he's like dude
they just came out in in australia that
uh
they stopped giving homework to kids in
australia they found that it was
that it sucked yeah that's that's
[ __ ] i was like he just died
and a boat
and just telling you his theories and
stuff they still have homework in
australia what are you talking about
maybe they don't i haven't lived there
for a long time i have to check that
did you get a green card for america do
i remember that right
i'm i'm a citizen i got a green card i
got a green card like eight nine
years ago and then you have to wait five
years and then
maybe two years ago i became a citizen
but i went i went and got sworn in and
all that type of stuff and it's like
it's funny because my ex my my son's
mother she was canadian
and she got it so i was at her
swearing-in ceremony and her swearing in
ceremony
uh uh obama was still the president now
i'm look i i think i'm a moderate or
whatever i don't want to get into
politics or whatever
and you know there's trump fans that
watch the show that your podcast but
but so obama gave this wonderful speech
and i remember crying
when she actually got sworn in like then
him just saying welcome to this country
you were now in america and all these
sort of these ugly uplifting words and
then like uh
and then when i got sworn in i had a
video from trump
and his video was just like hey it's a
fantastic wonderful country try to get
along with everybody and assimilate like
it was very
basic and it was just like a whole lot
of like mexicans going what are we doing
right now
good and they give you a little tiny
flag and you wave it
and then a video comes on the screen
that goes girls i'm proud to be
an american eagle fly for like four
minutes of that song
that's great wow are you are you a
citizen of canada too since you were
married to a canadian
no no i'm uh i just i still have my
australian passport but you i think you
can only have two passports i got
three what are you okay you got three
yeah my mom was born in canada my dad
was born in america and i was born in
england
they let you have three yeah yeah
because my son can have three
he's just my son my my ex and
um and me we had a debate over whether
he should get canadian or an australian
passport
and [ __ ] and i said oh probably better
if he gets australian passport you know
because it's different like he lives in
america already and then he can go to
australia it's a bit of a different
thing you know and my my ex is like
well what's wrong with canada why can't
he get a canadian passport
and i was like look i like canada as
much as the next man but
come on
that world canada and australia are both
notoriously difficult
countries to get into if you have a
criminal record i don't know
it might surprise you i don't have a
criminal record i've never been caught
for anything
i've talked i've talked openly about
drug use and all these things i don't
have a criminal record i've never been
arrested
that's great you know i i've gone out of
my way i've been arrested
quite a bit i imagine masturbating as
you jump out of a plane is a crime and
you put that online like
that feels like a crime to me yeah i
haven't put that online yet
but but i'm sure what's even creepier is
you
just sent that to me
[Laughter]
how have i seen it if you haven't put it
online how have i seen you jack up and
jump out of a plane
i showed it to you in person ah well
that's even more creepy
it's like that we were sitting around
and you said hey come over here
if we were in a workplace i'd be in hr
right away
yeah well we were we were over at uh
yours your studio where you taped the
comedy central show we were doing the
podcast after you're taping
well that's right well i'm all right
with it
you see your secret's safe with me
yeah so how long ago did you
tape intolerant uh i taped it back in
november of last year
and the problem was like so there's a
whole bit in the special about
how germaphobes are a pain in the ass
over stuff
it didn't date very well you know
it came out like a month ago and it's
like me getting [ __ ] germaphobes what
the [ __ ] do they know and now we're
living in this old covered
world it's like i started doing a new
a new show that i was touring because
the special was about to come out so i
did all new material
and i think i did about seven shows
before the lockdown happened
and my opening 20 minutes was about the
bushfires in australia
ah and like who gives a [ __ ] about that
anymore
that was that was february that that
whole country was burning down it was a
huge news story and now it just feels
like a lifetime ago
yeah it was really [ __ ] sad too man
we lost like a third of the koalas and
all that type of stuff and
there's something like 30 million 30
million mammals or something
something they lost a lot about it it's
funny that the koalas got all the press
because they were the
you know the only animals that didn't
run away from the fire
it's like they sleep for 22 hours a day
they just sat there and just got burnt
well the other animals were trying to
leg it out of there
and then we all go save the koalas save
the [ __ ] proactive animals like the
kangaroos that put effort into saving
themselves
yeah pull them up by their bootstraps
that's right yeah i think that in your
defense
the whole [ __ ] germaphobe germaphobes
thing
is uh is is pretty fair because it
turned out that
covet doesn't actually stay on cardboard
boxes so effectively
on cardboard boxes yeah like the fedex
boxes people were worried about
people were worried about receiving
their packages from amazon
like oh well this [ __ ] just touched it
and so now
what if i touch it i'm going to get
covered but the
the whole transferability on surfaces
really wasn't uh an issue at the end of
the day
so i'm with you on the germaphobes you
got to keep your immune system on its
toes
the bbc released a thing where where
guidelines on how you can have sex
during covert
and then there's strictly no kissing now
you're not to kiss during sex and i'm
like thank god i've been wanting that
from the beginning
i'm so happy to brought that brawl in
straight to it that's [ __ ] fantastic
i wonder how long uh it's it's gonna
like when do they run out of specials do
you think like uh how many
how many specials do they have in the
can where it keeps coming out it's all
this guy's got a new special
with the live audience like when does it
start getting a little bit weird oh wait
when does netflix just go tune into
eddie murphy's special
zoom yeah oh yeah it's like ufc
fights now right yeah i don't i don't
know i think
um i think they've got a lot of them but
the
you know the thing is what we're going
to do is we're going to get start to get
a lot of specialists from new zealand
comics
yeah i'll keep on producing those yeah
because new zealand's completely open
we'll just have we'll go
here's tom with his special flops
yeah in new zealand and south korea yeah
new zealand south korea
so steve called you a [ __ ] earlier you
said the word [ __ ] but like
cunt's not popular here so when you
first moved over here were you calling
people [ __ ]
and they were like well that's a
difficult one when i first got here
there was the one rule that was in the
comedy clubs was
you can't say [ __ ] and i'll say it again
i love
jim jeffries but you know what i don't
love how
hot it is i don't know what part of the
world you're in man but if it's anything
like it is here in los
angeles you are sweltering you know what
happened to me earlier today
i reached into my underwear and i i
scooped my balls
and then i made the mistake of smelling
my fingers it was so powerful it was so
overwhelming and i could not believe
that i didn't have on my ball deodorant
from manscaped
that's right ball deodorant guys it's
important
in this heat and you know what else in
this heat
you want to have your shirt off you want
to look good
you want to have your pubes groomed
gentlemen
so manscaped has you covered we've got
the
the lawnmower 3.0 it's amazing
we've got the weed whacker to take care
of that nose hair and the ear hair
we got the ball deodorant the foot
deodorant we got it all
and you can have it at a discount go to
manscaped.com
stevo and you get 20
off plus free shipping how about that
again
free shipping and 20 off your order if
you go to manscape.com
stevo now back to jim jeffries
and then i was like uh all right i'll
say it
and i just said it because i knew i'd
get away with it
and then they were like okay you can say
[ __ ] because no one was complaining
and then other comics would come in and
go why can't i say [ __ ] if he can't say
if he can say
[ __ ] and it became like when racists
want to say the n-word
and they're like he just said it in a
song i should be allowed to
and it's like and it's like no jim's
allowed and then
what happened was they went okay well i
guess you're you can you can say it too
and now
i i basically got rid of the [ __ ] band
in this country
15 years ago you couldn't say count the
comic clubs i'm telling you
i open i i open up the door
for you [ __ ] to say we should put a
statue in your name of a big [ __ ]
yeah i love it man i i wish there was a
[ __ ] counter
on intolerant because uh it's just i
tell you
if you watch my first special i swear to
god i'm a first special
i got i had an hbo i had an hbo special
with me first one hbo went
um is that the one with you with the
bottle you know that was that was the
one there was
there was one before the one with the
red background but in my first ever
special so i do
i'm doing i'm doing it they go look
you're fine to say anything it's hbo
you can say whatever you want but the
deal is that
the ratings work you know how ratings
work in 15-minute increments
right they want to see what your what
your attention is it's not
it's not enough for people to tune in
people have to tune in and watch all the
show you know
so so uh they said
they said we don't mind you saying [ __ ]
but we want everyone to stay for
at least 15 minutes so if you if you can
not say
[ __ ] for 15 minutes we'd really
appreciate it right so i had a
i had a [ __ ] light at the back of my
room at the back of the theater
that turned on at 15 minutes and i think
like 15 minutes and three seconds they
say aunt
aren't pandas a bunch of [ __ ] and then
i say cut throughout the whole
rest of it but if you watch that special
at the very beginning i don't say [ __ ]
i feel like in your in your early
specials you really
what made me fall in love with you
before we ever met was
your your uh bits about
christianity and and god are you really
just sticking it
sticking it to the whole religious
people and i really
loved that well i also find with that
that's a thing that that i was more
passionate about when i was younger i
still believe that religion's a load of
rubbish
but now i'm less i used to be so angry
at religious people you know what i mean
are you i used to be i used to be more
into religion as an atheist
than religious people were you know i i
was i i
used to make me so angry religion now
i'm just like ah live and let live
i think one of the privileges of being
an atheist
is you don't have to think about it you
know
it's it's strange that there's even a
word for atheism there shouldn't be a
word for it
for because believing in nothing because
there shouldn't be a
it's [ __ ] believing in a god but you
know i
i now i'm a bit more live and let livers
it's like if if that's what you want to
do with your life and you're not hurting
anyone go believe in your [ __ ] man in
a cloud if that makes you feel better
yeah i'm cool with that one time i met
an atheist
and he said uh i'm an atheist i
i don't believe in god i just believe
that the universe is
a sorry i believe that creation is a
an exercise in the universe experiencing
itself
and i was like yeah that's god yeah yeah
yeah that's a it's the most sound thing
you know what happened to me
around sort of 2008 2009
i started being invited to do atheist
conventions
and talk to them and and at that stage i
wasn't earning that much money and they
were paying me like
10 fifteen thousand dollars to go talk
at these atheist conventions and i was
like you know what
even if i find [ __ ] god i'm not gonna
tell anyone
nice were the people at those atheist
conventions
a bunch of [ __ ] well some of them were
a lot of them were very nice
but like this is this is a strange
ironic thing about maybe our irony
but a strange thing about really
religious professors
like really atheist professors they
don't half do the god look they've all
got like white beards
and long white hair and they're like
there's no god what's not gonna [ __ ]
look like in candy
yeah and then i i suppose yeah the
the the religion bashing kind of kind of
uh
faded out a little bit and then you had
the special with
the gun bit and that just changed your
whole life entirely didn't it
yeah the gun bit was something that that
happened
uh yeah i never thought it would take
off
it it it at one stage it was up to like
70 million hits or something before it
was taken down by netflix it was like 70
million now it's like 20 million or
something like that or
15 million or something and uh and so
all
up you know anywhere between 80 and 90
million
hits on on a comedy routine and i
started getting people
people started showing up to my shows
just wanting to hear me talk about
guns and and you know telling it how it
is and all that type of [ __ ]
and then i'm up there talking about
telling jokes about
[ __ ] getting things cut out of my
dick and and all that type of stuff you
know
and like my last special is like an
hour-long story about me [ __ ] myself
and i feel like a lot of people are very
disappointed you know
but the the gun thing it all i wrote
that routine
over the course of three days because
um i i was doing a tv show
i was doing a tv show called legit where
i was playing myself type of thing
and uh john ratzenberg who played cliff
clavin from cheers
the mailman who i'm still i'm still
friends with to this day i think he's a
great guy
and he's a republican or whatever so
he's pro-gun and
i grew up in a country without guns and
anyway so
i was with him when sandy hook happened
and he said ah
none of this would have happened jimmy
if those teachers had guns
and then i just argued with him and we
argued for three days and at the end of
that argument
i uh i had all the jokes already worked
out
to go on stage with you know for a
15-minute bit yeah i mean that bit i
sent it to my family
and my family absolutely [ __ ] loved
it
and then uh and then i came home to
visit and i was like oh let's watch that
comedian that you guys love
you know
we put on a whole special and my dad was
like yeah i can't do this
and so from from like a a business
perspective like a career perspective
there's really jim jeffries pre-gun bit
and then there's jim jeffries post gun
bit is that safe to say was that like
the
uh not really in stand-up but like
i wouldn't have gotten the jim jeffries
show if not for the gun bit you know
comedy central i think they brought me
in to do
something like that you know i could
have been a correspondent on the daily
show or something like that but
i didn't want to live in new york and
then and then you know i think after
they they had a tv show afterwards um
you know they had stephen colbert and
they tried some other things
to a couple of other people it didn't
work out i think i was just lazy because
they basically offered me the spot after
the daily show
and i said how about i just do something
once a week
and then you know i stupidly i stupidly
went and you know we do international
field pieces i just flippantly said that
in the in the meeting i said we could do
international field pieces
and then i did something like 50
international field pieces and had to
fly all over the world it was way more
work than doing a nightly show
i really [ __ ] myself on that one yeah
but it was fun to travel the world but
it was like you'd go into a town for
like one day
you do a piece on shark finning or
something like that then you're off to
south africa doing a bit on the
poverty over there then you'd be in
korea doing something about the
demilitarized zone you know and all that
stuff so i found
that was that was sort of the moment in
my career
where i was walking around going how the
[ __ ] did this happen
this didn't this was never in my plans
this feels like a very
off type of thing for me but my stand up
as such never changed
it was always sort of the same vibe but
like my tv career changed you know
at the moment i've i've got a i've got
i i've got a multi-cam sitcom in the
works for
for nbc and we were only six days out
from
being on set before cobra shut it down
all the sets were built and
type of stuff and a lot of people who
uh so-called fans of mine are doing that
whole
oh oh you're a shell out you sell out
you're doing a multi-cam sitcom and all
type of stuff
it's like you know there's lots of
uh you know comics have done multi-cam
sitcoms
who do edgy material bob saget did
multi-cam sitcoms and
you know even even at the richard pryor
show is in front of a studio audience
and stuff like that
you know it's not just clean comics like
bill cosby who do them
right yeah just tell them god has a plan
for you you know yeah yeah
yeah like you can say what you want
about bill cosby but in the end he
turned out to be pretty edgy
yeah i have a question jim it seems like
you make like a gun bit joke or an
atheist joke and everyone wants you to
be the spokesperson all of a sudden for
this like what's that feeling like do
you end up presenting
that um not real it doesn't yeah the
the atheist thing you know obviously as
i said i got to
i got to do shows about it and stuff
like that so that was interesting the
gun thing
the gun thing for me i every time there
was
a school shooting people i i turn my
phone on in the morning and wake up and
my
and my i just get text messages and
tweets and all these messages and i'd go
i i knew right away like there's been a
shooting because
so i've got 50 messages right yeah and
then
and then uh and then like oh thousands
on the [ __ ] twitter and what does
that right
so i i um what i didn't like was when
people would go
there'd be a squashing people go say
something jim
say something i'm like i've already said
it
just watch the routine again
copy and paste yeah yeah i don't have
any new information
for you yeah i'm still i still think
guns are
you shouldn't have them right
and and uh has there been a shooting in
australia
over all this time where they're just
well when i when i
did the routine when i did the routine
there was there was the famous shooting
and i believe
96 or something like that was the famous
i might
get that year wrong it was in the 90s
there was a guy in tasmania that shot a
lot of people
and that changed all the laws where we
had the gun ban and all that type of
stuff
now since i've done the routine i
believe there's been a couple of
smallish shootings a guy
i think a guy shot his family or out the
farm
you know and the bit that sort of
sickens me about that is when there is a
shooting in australia then all the gun
people
they must have hard-ons because they
[ __ ] write to me like
see see it doesn't work there either and
i'm like
okay settle you're talking about one
shooting in a decade
versus a shooting a [ __ ] week in this
in this country i think
i think there's one every day in america
yes there's one every day
or something like that i think you just
learned to live with it don't you just
go all right
this is how we live man at least that's
something that's probably slowed down
with kids not being in school anymore
how's it i mean in america and i think
there's distinctly less
shootings school zoom shootings yes zoom
shoots zoom shootings
which is which is weird because we're
all wearing masks it would be
so much easier to get away with yeah
right i'm not going to give anyone ideas
it's like but it's like when you go into
the bank and i literally went into the
bank
with a bandana tying around my face
going for sure give me a thousand
dollars please yeah
yeah like a bandit yeah yeah yeah and no
one said anything they just
give it to you so are you are you in la
right now
i am yeah are you gonna be one of the uh
celebrities that that
that leaves la are you gonna stay here
or you love it here oh
well this there's all these different
people leaving for
you know i don't know they i think it's
basically tax reasons that people leave
i think people leave
california for tax purposes yeah i got
my ex here and my kid here and he has to
go between so i'm not going anywhere
you know i'm just staying here until the
bitter end oh i alright class
class little let everyone [ __ ] leave
go
leave let's travel i'll i'll be fine
yeah i want to show you my my mask i
made
yeah that's that's a delight
that's it that's that's [ __ ] have you
worn that out in public i have
yeah it's it's a little bit weird i get
you know i
i prepare to go into a gas station i
think am i going to do this
[ __ ] yeah what kind of reaction did you
get steve
i haven't had a really strong one i've
had a couple compliments
uh nobody else has said anything do
people know it's you or they
i don't know if they know it's me that's
hilarious yeah because you
because your voice isn't distinctive or
anything no one's gonna be able to crack
the code
your voice sounds like it has been
gargling come for a long time
yeah about right actually actually that
would probably make it make it smoother
i don't know
but i feel like you can get arrested for
that though right that's that's indecent
what's happening i wonder i i actually
shot that
um and i shot that image by filling my
mouth with
uh dishwashing liquid so it's actually
uh
it's a clean out to come
[Laughter]
something like that
and you shot it when you were 11.
yeah that's an old photo
oh my god i i love you jim jeffries i i
love you so much dude
what's coming up for you are you just
because you had a show in tulsa
pretty soon right yeah we saw it got
postponed or something right on the show
all my shows were for spain until
further
i did one of those shows the other day
in front of a whole lot of cars at the
magic castle have you done that
no there's a there's a gig of the magic
castle in the car park where you just
you go on and perform look they're doing
they're really doing the best they can
it's a beautiful stage and
they give everyone little clapping
things to hang out their sunroof and
clap when they enjoy a joke
but it's uh you know it's the best we've
got right now but i i think i'm gonna
wait
until comedy's up and running again i
don't know
it's it's just not fun without them all
laugh without
hearing them laugh i don't know because
there's a lot of comics doing zoom
shows have you done a zoom show i have
not i can't do that
yeah i don't know if it's yeah i don't
know if it's
sort of i don't know if it's for me so i
think i'll just wait
until the time comes again or i'm just
going to go 2 in new zealand
yeah i'm going to go to countries
without covert and just tour
did i when you did the magic castle show
didn't
when people really liked it joke did
they honk their
horn well they were they were i
i asked them to honk the horn if they
didn't they didn't like what i was doing
and then a whole lot of people started
hogging their
but then i was told afterwards you're
not meant to do that because the council
all the people that live in houses
around there were complaining about
people honking their horns
yeah so you're not you're not to do that
but you know there was
you know bill burr was on the gig and it
was there was people there it was like a
real
thing how many how many cars yeah how
many cars you got in the crowd
oh i i couldn't give you an exact number
but there was a lot of cars there but
you know when you get like
you know when you get like uh people
walking out of coney clubs because they
don't like their
your routines
people drive out they didn't do it to me
but i don't want to
tell anyone else's stories but other
comics were doing routines and
people were driving out oh my god you
got a truck like
they want to be respectful of the
neighbors so they hand out little golf
clappers
like these little slappy hand things
click right right quite quiet like
and do this do they cue it into the
radio or is it just over a loud speaker
and you can just hear it no they
just don't they just have their windows
open okay and they're all parked so
close to each other they could be
standing but
you know i was saying about this like
like how many people
in that audience are getting [ __ ]
the answer is some right yeah at least
the hand job
more than at a comedy club and my other
gigs no one is
right so that's nice and people would
just be doing cocaine in their car no
one would be
worrying about that so there's there are
some positives to the audience doing
this
i mean where people drinking beer in
their car obviously right so yeah you
can you can order beers
you can order beers and they come to you
like you're a carhop
you know what i mean like they come and
deliver the bees you order the beers on
an app
and they'll even bring you the magic
castle food you can get some chicken
wings and some whatever they're gonna
serve you
and uh a beer and a bottle of wine and
they'll bring it to your car
and drive home drive home drive on home
dude that's great how old are you now
43. 43. i've just turned 46.
i got to say uh even though you're a
little younger
i think that when you get to my age
you're going to look better
well i'm i'm gained 20 pounds in covert
i've
i'm actually 20 20 right now i've
reached away
yeah i put on the covet 19.
that's pretty good yeah i have a
question about the word [ __ ]
is um are is america the most sensitive
about that word or are there other
places where it's by far
by far we're the most by far america the
america's problem with the word [ __ ] is
the connotation a connotation that
it's against women right where the rest
of the world just see it like
like this you can call a man a [ __ ] a
woman a kind and think it's
it's and it's not about it's not about a
woman being evil
you can say i i've always said that the
word [ __ ] can be used
friendlier than [ __ ] and you guys use
bachelor
right so if so if i say i say oh my
mate's coming over he's a right cunning
is
check out this [ __ ] ah get out of here
get out of it you bloody [ __ ]
what are you doing [ __ ] off your [ __ ]
right
where if you go my friend's going over
she's the right [ __ ] she is
this [ __ ] over here get out of it you
[ __ ]
right it's just more aggressive right it
is yeah
[ __ ] is a term of endearment and and
that's it
it can be it can be yeah we were walking
around we were walking around south
africa
calling people [ __ ] and they're like
yeah we don't say that here
so we kind of felt about that yeah
that's australia yeah
yeah but they do use the word colored
over there so
you know
when you first hear that in south africa
you go what the [ __ ] was that
when they first say that word that one
amazed me
yeah well well [ __ ] hey jim jeffries
dude thank you so much for doing this
man
and uh i just i just can't tell you how
much of a fan i am dude i really do love
you
thanks guys i love you too mate thanks
for having me i really appreciate it
hell yeah brother right on me right on
dude what did i tell you
it was the funniest episode we've
recorded
and here we are talking to the people
who hung in there to the very end you
guys
know how much i love you how much i
appreciate you
you are the street team and please
let jim jeffries know how much
i appreciated him doing this and and how
much
you appreciated him doing this by taking
a screenshot anywhere on the podcast
and posting it with the tag for jim
jeffries tag me
i mean that'll mean the world to me just
to let him know how
[ __ ] funny this was and that's it
thank you
unless you want to watch gnarly at
stevo.com but you probably already did
so thank you